Hello everybody, welcome in!
Howdy, howdy!
Konminto!
Welcome back to Dudley Promenation Part 5, Obchat, thank
you.
This is Good Minto Evening.
Good Minto Evening!
Today, I will not be yapping so much.
I'm sorry.
As much as I would love to talk to you guys.
Because I have so much to do.
I'm sorry.
I want to be- I want to play more of the game.
I want to get into the title.
What?
What is it?
Wait.
Yes.
Um...
Yeah, she's a gamer.
She's a gamer.
Hello, Vito, and I was like, you hope you were able to get
your moving supplies smoothly.
I was.
I ran out of tape.
I can't wait for more adventures with Vito and Zach.
Thank you.
I ran out of tape.
And I cannot make more boxes and seal boxes if I have no
tape.
It's my birthday tomorrow.
Oh, no, Dr. Thunder Sneeper.
Sneeper.
I won't be streaming tomorrow, so happy birthday!
Actually, don't listen until tomorrow.
Happy birthday!
This game is the gift that keeps on giving.
It is absolutely a game.
So, um, so, quick question.
What's the lore behind the hot dog suit on the moped?
I like it a lot, but was wondering what the story was.
Great question.
I say hot dog, and I also like moped.
That's about it.
It's not deep at all.
The story is hot dog.
Venmo app.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
I find my...
Wait, about the is combat event.
How did you manage to get the invitation from Bandai?
Do they know you because you accidentally...
I didn't leak their...
game but no they invited me they just sent me an email they
sent an email and asked if i wanted to go easy easy easy
peasy i'm no longer nesting you are you're back to resting
oh for how long i guess you have to thank you for the dog
the dog Oh, were we raided?
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Invisible Moose.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
There were some some people at Bandai Namco that like said
that they were fans of me and Matara.
So yeah, I guess I guess they know that I played this
combat.
So...
Oh...
So yeah.
Invisible mood, thank you!
Resting glitches, thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
What better state of mind for deadly premonition than to be
sleep deprived?
Oh gosh.
Have work while driving.
Oh no, that's even worse.
Whilst Minky solves wacky mysteries, please give me strength
to stay awake.
I will try and be as obnoxious, which is very easy.
easy for me i'll be loud and obnoxious and crazy i'll be
like it's an honor to be invited by big publisher i've i
felt very honored i still feel very honored i still feel a
little in disbelief that they would invite me it was a lot
of fun though i'm very i'm very happy i'm like i said i've
never gone to a game event like that before so It was really
cool that they would...
That they would think that I'm cool enough to go.
Your secret little adventure was worth it.
Famous Minke number one bazaar.
What are we talking about?
Oh, I meant to say too.
I am once again playing this game without headphones on.
I'll do my best.
Honestly, I'm a little...
I might put them... I might put on my headphones during the
stream, but...
Mint, please make this next week go by fast for me.
Dongai!
Okay, well, if I make it...
Okay, if I suck the time from you and give it to me, so my
week feels slow, because I feel like I'm really running out
of time and I'm stressed very much.
I...
Um...
sure your time can go fast your week can go fast and my week
can go slow yeah i need more time for packing i've been up
yesterday i was up until like 4 a.m 7 5 1 1 2 3 2 welcome to
membership tag or welcome back to membership thank you we're
having birthday it is my birthday once again i haven't been
here for a while but i am here Come back!
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I might need a different cord for this.
Actually, I'll just scoot over.
I forgot to charge my controller from last time.
I was trying to turn it on and I was like...
I forgot to mention...
Oh my gosh, yesterday I was recording stuff for like four
hours before stream.
And then I thought the game would be voice acted, but it
wasn't.
And so I talked for seven hours.
my voice was so sore afterwards so I'm gonna try and take it
easy today I'm doing my best I did get to meet up I got to
meet up with a friend of mine
the only person I hang out with but it's the last time I get
to hang out with her for probably a very very very long time
so we went to some cafes and it was fun and yeah it was nice
it was nice so I did get to I did I did get to relax just a
little bit earlier today we went to this one cafe and like
it was like a how do I describe it it's
like it was like super trendy I guess is what you would call
it super trendy and I was like whoa I showed up in my in my
pink sweats and I was like whoa whoa I feel like I'm an
Instagram world but I'm still drinking actually my coffee
from it
my the coffee everything was so expensive it was one of
those types of places where I was like, she, she, she has
like, uh, she sends me Instagram reels of like places that
she wants to go with me.
She even has like a special folder of Instagram reels that
says, uh, date spots with Minto.
And, uh, FK in the coffee.
So she was just like, this one we have to go to before you
leave.
Like, you must go to this one with me.
And we went, I was like, I feel.
I felt like I was in California.
You know what I mean?
Everybody was so trendy.
California people scare me.
California people, they frightened me.
I feel like too many people are the extroverts there.
I don't know.
I got asked to film a TikTok.
Sorry, we don't try to be less scary.
I've never been asked to film a TikTok before.
And I was like, they were like, can you like zoom in a
little bit more on us?
and this, ah, oh, us introverts exist here.
We just stay indoors.
Yeah, California introverts here.
We just don't go out.
I don't blame you.
I've never done it.
You don't even film your own TikToks.
I've filmed no TikToks before.
Introvert on the outside, extrovert on the inside.
How?
Can we ask for a TikTok filming at a meet and greet?
We'll do a TikTok dance together.
Catch my heart, catch my heart.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
We can do it.
We can do a TikTok dance together.
Rito just starts flossing like it's 2016.
This is still trendy, right guys?
Flossing will come back, though.
Just you wait.
Everybody should dab at the beat and greet.
You guys laugh about this until the day I'm like...
There are sometimes, like, idols, they'll be like...
They'll do a show.
They'll do, like, a...
live show and then they'll be like okay audience we want to
film a tick tock now so learn these moves and do them with
us like during during like mc or at the end of the show or
something and you laugh but one day i'll be like okay
everybody we're gonna do a tick tock together catch my heart
catch catch my heart
You all do it.
That's...
That's the evolution.
That's actually a little scary.
It's a threat.
It's an actual threat.
We're gonna do the punch punch.
You can't force us.
I can.
I can send little Ratatouille's.
If you don't do the damage, I would be like, release the
wretch.
And then little, many wretch would scamper all over the
floor and run up your back and cling to your clothes and
grab your hair and then force you to dance.
Dance, my little, my little Aibus dance.
Minto, say jump, you ask how high.
Yeah.
Dance.
Please, now I'm scared.
Why do you think I'm moving to the rat factory?
I'm not, I'm renouncing my maiddom.
I'm not going to haunt the maid cafe anymore.
I'm going to haunt the rat factory so I can produce rats
that will, that will grab your hair and make you dance.
Promise me I can do the punch punch.
sets i boost they do the punch punch time to make some
coffee to witness the future to be only to witness the
flossing meet the video if you do that away to you and me so
says mr stewart hi everyone welcome our dark monkey overlord
yes who do you think is controlling me right now are you
guys ready for well that we last ended deadly premonition
well we were going back into So, let's get ready for that.
Let's get excited.
Gosh, I'm rich.
I'm so rich.
It's awesome.
Yay, Terror Dungeon.
Oh, God.
Kaysen.
Thomas, did you see Nick here?
I...
George, stay back.
She's trying to speak.
This was wild.
Oh, please.
You got us good this time, Zach.
That was craziness.
George killed that girl.
Yeah, he did.
All right.
Let's get it going.
Yeah.
Why did that happen?
Did they notice me?
Was that a jump scare?
That's a jump scare.
Oh shoot.
I forgot how to shoot.
Bullseye.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Oh shoot.
Yeah.
Okay.
Phew.
Wait, what about the one in the back?
Don't leave!
Dang it!
Wait, maybe I can get it from here.
Dang.
Don't want to die.
This area looks pretty spooky, I'm not gonna lie.
Here's somebody.
Oh gosh, this is pretty tough without my headphones.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, uh, where's my, where's my pointer?
Oh, there it is.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, where'd my pointer go?
Oh, there.
Nice!
We cleaned that up, too.
We'll be here either, as you will.
It's hard to read, though, while I'm walking around.
We got a knife.
I don't want to die.
We're in the currently the back basement of the art gallery.
There was like a little shed behind the art gallery and oh
that's him.
I thought somebody was yeah I haven't shaved in a minute.
This is strategic.
Stop?
Stop doing that?
I was doing it to block in any potential suitors.
But now I'm stuck.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
That's a lot of blood.
Even more blood.
I'm observing.
Droplets of blood from the ceiling.
The blood's still fresh.
Could it be the victims?
Nice shot, York.
Thanks, York.
Just kind of learn on my watch that my stress level has
been...
hide for an extended period.
Thank goodness you're here, Vento.
Phil, are you okay?
It's not the game, is it?
I feel like I get that way with this game.
I'm not gonna lie.
Why is there blood on the ceiling?
Oh my gosh, that scared me.
Where's that dashing fellow?
Can we go in here?
It looks like a...
There's...
The blood leads into there.
Is there any way for me to...
Huh.
What the heck is that noise?
But um...
What is this?
Hello?
I'm observing?
A pale portrait of a red background.
Oh, a pale portrait on a red background.
I thought it said of a red background.
I was like, are we not...
Address me.
Are we not going to talk about the man in the photo?
Greeting us with a creepy smile.
What is this?
Oh, they...
What is...
Okay, I...
I did it.
Thank you for my mom.
money.
What is the sound?
It's really annoying, actually.
It's like clearly something in the vents, but speaking of,
did anybody watch the first episode of the Among Us anime?
What
was that?
You can watch the first episode for free on YouTube, which
is why I watched it.
I heard it was actually good.
So I was like, now I'm even more curious.
Unless Oh.
It's just some, like, paid shill from Paramount.
Oh, what is happening?
What's happening?
Don't jump scare me.
Oh.
What's happening?
Oh, no!
Creepy!
What are you?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Jeff the killer!
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
They're invisible on...
I could see you though.
Shooting you in the ass.
Evade?
Oh okay.
Sure.
Oh shoot.
I hope there's nothing behind me.
Sick of aid, I know right.
Oh!
I'm stuck!
Just kidding.
Is this a boss?
Is this our first boss?
It sure feels like it.
Aved, evade, evade!
I just stand in the corner.
Just a quirky guy.
Yay!
Samara's not very good at this.
I will take that, thank you.
Actually, I probably could use it.
Let's use it real quick.
My health is not.
It could be better.
And of course, if the audio is loud or strange, it's hard
for me to hear at the moment.
So please, you can yell at me.
Nice!
That was a boss of all time.
We did it, we did it.
Zach, did you check that out?
Uh-oh.
Oh, money.
Run!
Oh my gosh, did we make it out?
Where are we going?
As good as it can be with this game.
Very fair.
Oh, we made it to a new place!
Let's go!
Oh, I maybe didn't need to use the thing, huh?
Save.
Yes.
Alright!
What's this?
Oh, take that?
Yeah?
Let me see.
A sugar donut!
Yeah, it's okay, Minto.
We know you're getting older and can't hear that.
Well, aglow.
Speak up.
I can't hear your super chat.
Our sleep is okay.
My head's kind of blocking it.
It's okay.
We could take a nap for like an hour in this dusty, crusty
room.
Sleep for one hour.
Light sleep.
Nice, there we go.
They allow us to sleep and give us breakfast, too.
This place is so hospitable.
Vivi Gord, thank you so much for the five gifts, then.
In fact, let's, yeah, yeah, let's eat, too.
What brush are we in?
What?
It's not like people are dying or anything.
Nice.
Some good carbs.
Okay.
so loud all right okay this the donut was not on the floor
it was on that plate there i think we're good though oh wait
i do there was one thing i wanted to get out of the toolbox
was another take item out wait did that say panda bear what
does that mean
I've seen what happens if you get killed by Zombo.
It's genuinely unhinged.
We'll try it today.
I have not actually.
Oh, it's the shop.
I mean, though, I was late to stream before you start gaming
because I was just finishing the bottom of the last gently
premonition stream.
Just in time.
Lollipop.
Thank you.
Welcome in.
A sword.
A saber.
Reach long.
Speed.
How is the speed slow?
It's a sword.
Eurability medium.
Strength high.
Um, hell yeah, I'm gonna get this sword.
I acquired sword.
These are actually reasonable prices.
Like, wait.
When it's launched, a patrol car will come soon.
It's for an emergency.
I see.
Finish.
And then go back.
Take item out.
Well, now I'm taking out the sword.
Oh, I guess I do have the sword.
Never mind.
I was going to do like the golf club or the steel pipe or
something.
But we have a sword.
So...
Wait.
Let's take this out.
Okay.
Never mind.
Let's not take it up.
My little prize is when you consider what crackers cost.
A cookie is like $40 in this game.
Oh!
Call me Ryden.
Nice.
Awesome.
Okay, I'll save one more time since we bought watch some
more stuff he's ready the genre the game has changed
entirely so where are we now are we in the okay it's still
gross in here so we're not quite done is this the art
gallery itself now but in hell we're
playing Sekiro we We switched genres, everybody.
Now we are...
Okay.
We're so chill, man.
We're so normal.
Is this a puzzle?
This is the entrance hall.
Oh, it's this again!
That tree!
Apples.
I bleep it.
Remember to collect enemy electrolytes to restore your
health.
Oh.
Why am I prof...
We haven't profiled in a bit, so...
Oh, this is a new one!
What are you doing here?
Instead of this develops in Japan, I feel like they're
converting it into dollars, but they've got to change the...
That could be it.
I'm not into this.
this stuff.
What's happening?
Do you know in which movie they use the sword?
That's right.
Samurai cop, a true masterpiece.
He even spoke blue Japanese.
This is a long one.
Sir?
Too much noise.
Still missing a vital piece of the puzzle.
Yes.
Put down.
What am I putting down?
The master key.
I think I need that.
I don't think it's the right one.
Okay, so our puzzle...
Alrighty.
What's this?
say anything?
No.
Where's... Okay, we have this...
Why does this look like it will come to life?
Is it just me?
Like, it looks like it's a...
Okay.
Pass the tree.
I wonder once we do the puzzle if it'll come to life.
Maybe.
Parents will always say my baby is the beautiful, most
beautiful baby in the world and this is what it looks like.
This guy too, right?
Maybe it'll come alive once we figure out the puzzle.
Ooh, why is the staircase doing that?
Stop, you're making me dizzy.
Oh.
Oh, you have the apples on you.
Huh?!
Oh my god.
Wait.
There's not guys coming after me, are there?
Oh my gosh.
Hello?
Where's the second one?
Or the third one?
There.
For some reason I cannot see where my pointer is this time.
Take.
Okay, we got a ripe apple.
We got...
A red apple.
And a green apple.
Uh...
Oh my gosh, please.
Where was the old man?
Over here?
Yes.
He has...
Uh...
Oh my god.
Oops.
Green apple.
Red.
Just the way I like them.
Looks a bit too ripe for me.
Let's do the red apple?
Oh, just kidding.
He doesn't think it's the right one.
Uh, put down another one.
The red apple?
Oh, oh, sorry.
I meant the ripe one.
I forgot.
I thought that I put down the ripe one at first.
Okay, ripe?
Okay.
Ripe and juicy, just how he likes him.
To the baby, to the baby, to the baby, to the baby, to the
baby.
Green apple?
Why is it so hard to see?
Everything is still purple.
Why is it getting bored and bored?
Red apple, just the way he likes him.
Yay!
Oh, here she comes.
There it is, yeah.
Oh, all the stuff went away.
Oh, you have a...
Nice shot.
Yes.
Thank you.
Don't want to die.
I want to kind of use my sword.
Where'd the last lady go?
Hello?
Was there anyone up there?
Don't think so.
Oh, there's the last one.
She's confused.
A little confused.
Amazing, he says.
Nice shot.
Thank you.
Is there one upstairs?
Oh, there was one upstairs.
I'll get them all.
Oh, where is she?
Oh, there she is.
Oh, gosh.
What is she holding?
She's got a gun!
Nice shot.
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
That was a close one.
She's got a gun.
What do you have here?
Wait, but I want the shotgun!
Do you think if I go into the previous room?
Wait, no, the safe room, it...
No!
Wait, I'll just toolbox it.
Okay, good.
We can take it.
We'll get it out later.
Huge.
Huge reveal.
I think we're fine with our sword rather than the...
What is this?
Oh, red seeds.
She came out of the painting.
I must have been so shocked.
I was.
I've never heard of that before.
A red seed could be an important clue in solving this case.
You got red seed.
Have we not been collecting these our entire career?
I'm confused.
What?
You.
I still think it's Kesa.
Oh, Hamidou!
Don't!
Don't grab my face!
Oh my god, he stabs her!
Oh my gosh!
Blood's so red.
Any face grabbers here in the chat?
All head crabs raise their hands.
Me!
Me, my lord!
Hmm.
Quit grabbing faces.
Wait a second, was that the door over here?
Our safe room!
If I go back in here, if I...
I wonder if the enemies will return.
I'm gonna save real quick, though.
I'm gonna grab the shotgun and save, too.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, it was right here.
All xenomorphs raising their hands, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's get the shotgun first.
I...
You know, I learned something recently.
I feel so goofy, too, is I...
had thought that the um oh good okay we do have shotgun
shells i had thought that the alien on the alien ride of
disney was xenomorph i believe that for like my entire
afterlife and then i learned recently it was not xenomorph
and i'm i feel like a dang fool i'm like wait Who are you?
I saw...
I watched like a video of the ride recently and I was
like...
Wait a second.
Who are you?
Because I feel like, you know, sometimes Disney just has the
most random properties that they...
that they just have.
You know what I mean?
Apparently you're not the only one.
Yeah, it's just like some random alien.
Did I save?
Wait, did I save?
No.
Thank you.
Disney now owns the alien franchise, though.
That's probably why I thought so, you know?
Because...
Ah, I was so convinced.
I was like, oh my gosh, of course, my queen.
And then...
No.
Oh, oops.
My bad.
Not at all.
Oh my gosh, vanilla.
Thank you so much for the pink.
I asked for a raise recently and got a lot more than I
expected.
Let's go!
You're taking the initiative.
So thank you for all the hours of singing, gaming, and
yapping, and for all the behind the scenes work you put in.
Seeing you work so hard for us motivates me to do my best
to.
Vanilla pee!
Thank you!
No, I'm so proud of you.
Thank you so much!
and congratulations
yeah yeah that's cool
anything else over here nope that was probably before Disney
owned the alien franchise I think it probably was but in my
brain I was like oh well they own it so alien the ride
sounds like it must be what it says it is oh my gosh all
these stupid places are now like red vines are entangled
around the guiding rope a no-go for sure what do you mean
for sure it's the size it's literally like smaller than a
child you can just step over them
ah Is this like a maze?
Okay, this area might be a little bit of a annoyance to us.
Actually, let's shotgun.
Alright, who's coming out first?
Which way do I go?
Oh.
I'll take that.
I'll tool that.
He's allergic to red vines.
Deathly actually.
Deathly allergic.
Oh.
Oh, that stunned him like crazy.
Oh, shoot.
Nice!
Two hit.
Two hit wonder.
We'll wait till they're a little closer.
Okay, I think that's the one thing about this weapon is,
um...
Oh.
Everybody's a little slow, and I also like to be far away.
Just eat the vines.
Two years every!
Jacob, thank you!
Thank you so much!
Oh, wow!
Nice!
Wait, what the was that?
Please don't come out of the wall.
Special exhibition room, kid.
Whoa!
Anything could be a sniper rifle if you're yeah.
Who's to say that this game follows, uh, you know,
things the way guns should be, right?
We haven't heard him talk to Zack at once this entire time
so far.
Observe?
Probably shouldn't try to get in here.
Okay.
Why not?
Oh,
I hear somebody.
It makes me so nervous.
Holy cow.
I have a shotgun.
Nice.
Wait, I thought you don't want to die.
boobies is that what he just said something something
boobies sir yeah he teleported through my gun we should
probably save this honestly for when we truly need it sir
this is an art gallery actually um actually that's probably
like the perfect place to see boobies.
Art galleries are acceptable boobie observation areas.
It's a publicly accepted boobie staring zone.
Art galleries and hooters.
Broken stiletto heel shoe.
Again?
The whole shoe?
You are actually right.
I know.
I'm usually right.
You can trust me.
I won't steer you in the wrong direction.
Have you ever been to Twin Peaks restaurant?
I have not.
Okay, I have two problems with Twin Peaks.
Actually, one problem.
I've never been to Twin Peaks.
But now I feel like I must go because of everything that I
have...
um encountered alan wake and deadly premonition i have to
watch i have to watch twin peaks i feel like i would go if i
were in the the the the spooky forest area but my issue is
twin peaks it's spelled p-e-a-k right like the mountain
peaks i get it i get the pun the twin peaks are the But why
isn't it Twin Peaks?
P-E-E-K.
Like, why can't it be an even more pun?
I wonder if Art Exhibit staff get confused when patrons
throw $1 bills at the basics.
It could be Twin Peaks.
Yeah.
You taking a little Twin Peak?
Two on the nose?
Maybe.
maybe I guess you're right
also a restaurant that copied Hooters I don't think Hooters
owns sexy girls you know have you guys ever heard of hold on
I'm looking it up
I can't remember the name of it actually
uh uh The Tilted Kilt.
Have you guys ever heard of the Tilted Kilt?
The Tilted Kilt.
That one is the sexiest of them all.
In my opinion.
Yes, actually.
I think I love plaid.
Okay.
Minky did the research.
I did.
Valid.
Plad outfit win.
You know, actually, I try to make my outfits easy for
artists, so I would never do plaid.
I would not put Ayami Mama through that.
That would be hellish.
Mint has a thing for Octoberfest outfits.
Yeah.
really angry at me for staring at their chest.
Now I am banned from the museum.
chest!
Freaky light!
But frills are okay.
Look, I can't help what my first outfit was.
But my second outfit has minimal frill.
And third outfit has minimal frill.
Anyway.
A stiletto heel shoe broken.
Becky must have sent these with her letter.
We got the shoe.
What a thrill.
Let's profile.
I like the profiling each time.
You know, Taco Lof, it's fun to draw.
You think so?
I'm so happy.
Oh, wait.
I guess we didn't profile?
Oh, I forgot to press the button.
I'm stupid.
This here's a plaid texture like they did in Chowder.
I do like that effect.
I think it's pretty fun.
Hey, lady.
Come here.
Nice.
Anyway.
Don't want to die.
They don't even have time to say don't want to die.
They're just gone.
Nice.
The money is a trap.
You don't need the money.
I need the money!
Nice.
Disney is the great movie ride.
Was the one that had alien movie section with actual
xenomorph.
Oh!
Looking forward to the NYC concert.
Thank you!
Babjin, thank you.
It's not a trap.
Sorry that I walk through all of these dungeons.
I just don't want to get got, you know what I mean?
I'm a cautious ghost.
I'm a cautious little ghost, okay?
I know some people are like, does Minky remember that
there's a run button?
And I do.
I just, uh...
I just...
Don't...
You know what?
Maybe we run here.
Open!
Oh,
downstairs.
What the hell is this snarling for?
I hear somebody.
Oh!
Maybe they were outside the door.
Oh, yeah, I think they were outside the door.
Oh, great.
Now I hear her everywhere.
I think?
That sounds a little sussy.
Oh, oh, oh, textures.
Wall textures.
It sounded kind of sussy, no?
Why is the fog doing that?
I thought it was a glass shelf.
Oh
my god, oh my god!
Did that guy just fall on the ground?
Oh, everybody died.
I killed them all?
Whoa.
Wait, how did I do that?
Double kill!
Oh!
I love you, shotgun.
Somebody in the chat?
Link, link, changing my name to shotgun.
What's that?
Oh!
The upside down piece!
Kid name shotgun.
I must be easily suggestible when I'm tired.
I repeatedly heard I don't need money, so I guess this is
yours.
Will it down!
Aren't you driving?
Stop!
An upside down piece mark has been drawn in blood on this
circular painting.
Not part of her collection, I figure.
The last key!
Profiling!
start you what are you doing here so it was you much more
astonishing than I imagined I'm not
into this stuff Nicholas thank you so much for the 10 get
that upside down piece
what's it doing in our dresser or our desk oh my god
dragging her around doesn't isn't it being upside down
depend on which way you look at it from yeah I think notes
upside down.
That was actually scary.
I was also thinking the same thing though.
To this game I saw every Tremors movie on the best streaming
service.
YouTube free movies one and two are good.
Three is okay but added a new species.
Skip the rest.
Thank you murderers folly.
I'll heed your suggestion.
That was spooky.
That was pretty scary.
Wait, are we gonna fight that guy again?
The handsy man?
Let's go down.
All we can go is down.
Rory Shock Peace Test.
Is it good or evil?
Oh good, there's a save here.
Are we?
We about to do like a boss boss?
Was that a mini boss before?
I still have to pay!
This scam of a gallery!
Scam!
Are you hiding in the...
in the vents again?
Wait.
Was this...
Was this where we came from?
But with boxes?
Where are we?
Sorry, I'm checking.
Because...
Where do we go?
Wait, what?
Oh, there's another hall.
They're back!
I wonder if I should shotgun them.
Oh, dang it, I missed my chance.
Oh, wait, no.
Abade!
No!
Oh, okay.
Yay!
I'm reloading.
It's wriggling at us!
Let's use my sword here.
Oh,
I can climb up!
Oh, it's fine.
I'm getting money.
This is where we...
No.
Do we have to fight it again?
Yeah, this is where we...
Yep, there it is.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, it's in a much smaller space, though.
Oh.
Okay.
I wait.
You?
It's kind of sexy.
I say you, but...
Oh, evade, evade!
Holy cow.
That was close.
Oh, I'm ready.
They're doing something.
I don't know what that means.
Oh.
Hmm.
Pro-gamer moves.
I think we'll have to fight it again even.
Oh my goodness.
Again again?
How many more times?
Okay.
Yeah?
Dodge, dodge.
Or evade, evade, evade.
There.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, I didn't know.
I mean to move it to my...
Okay.
Nice shot.
Okay, are we gonna have to do it again?
Oh!
Actual zombie!
Boy, I got them both, though.
That was kind of crazy.
Actual zombie.
I feel so powerful with this thing.
I'm not gonna lie.
La la la, making my way back.
Uh-huh.
Oh.
Go!
The wall ladies were so hard in the OG game.
Lucky.
Really?
They love me.
I believe it, though.
I 100% believe it.
Yeah!
They were a pain.
The controls are so clunky in this- Should we shave?
Look at our sick beard, though.
We'll shave.
Should we shave?
I missed- wait, did I miss much yesterday with the Moomin
game?
I saw that you went a bit longer than usual.
If you want a cozy, nice, relaxing stream, then you can
watch.
It's pretty goofy.
I'm not gonna lie.
Keep the beard.
Keep the beard?
Okay, we'll keep the beard.
What's my health and stuff looking at?
Or not health, my...
Okay, we're asleep and food are good, so...
Oh.
Wait, but I solved the case!
Get me out of here!
I'm not stinky, I think.
Okay.
That beard says I'm big beef.
Welcome back, thank you so much.
What?
There's more?
Oh, maybe this is where we discover her body.
Leave the beard.
I want to see how big it is.
Down to our toes.
Oh, it's back to normal.
Nick.
Nick!
Oh, he's alive?
I think?
He sounded like he groaned a little.
Uh?
Drippy.
No!
Oh,
isn't he drunk?
What's his name?
Yeah, George.
Isn't George drunk right now?
Oh.
I'm gonna put my headphones on.
It's a little hard to hear.
I can't tell.
The volume in this game is crazy.
Diane?
George, call for assistance with the body.
She's still alive!
Oh my god, she is!
She's gonna get impaled.
Don't move, yeah, don't move.
Don't move her hands and stay still.
Are you for real?
He just said!
I'm going to I'm going to why he just told you not to move
but oh my god George is gonna kill a second woman have can
we check his back again oh my god oh my god she's gonna be
impaled are you stupid jump
jump York jump catch us
watch this sick flip she's like an angel catch us look at
him at the wide stance
that was sick is she still alive after the concussion
Thomas call an ambulance What oh my god Thomas please Agent
York George are you okay Call an ambulance for me too I
think I'm too old to be an acrobat though Yeah the statue is
loose now Maybe we should uh She should be able to tell us
who did this to her we should move her away from it maybe
but you george quite a catch i am impressed hmm what george
what's happening what is he possessed oh oh actually no i
think his reaction Daya?
This reaction is valid?
Okay.
She's talking without her tongue.
Eroticism?
From the tree?
You know what?
That is the first thing I thought when I saw it.
I think I understand art.
She's like...
Ew, she's like...
There's like seeds coming out of her Really?
Yeah Of course Stop right there, Nick You're under arrest
for the attempted murder of Diane Ains Wait, what?
Why?
Is him?
Wait What?
Back off!
Don't touch me!
Oh no!
At least Emily has some sense trying to save her.
Did everybody get out of the way?
Oh, I guess not.
Oh my god!
Still holding on to her!
That's traumatizing, I think.
Oh my god!
The mocap in this game is so goofy, but sometimes it's
really good.
Like here?
Like the mocap, the facial mocap, is really good here.
I requested...
And...
Thomas...
We'll need a body pack too.
Oh, not our guts.
Just on the ground.
This is all your fault, actually.
Teldern, welcome back to Mumbusha, thank you.
We're redeemed and unredeemed at the same time.
Shut up, Nick.
Shut the hell up.
Can you hear that?
What is it?
You guys hear something?
Oh.
Kason.
Funky music.
Here comes the dog.
He's good.
I think he wants us to follow him.
Shall we follow Zach?
What did I do?
I'm sorry.
The game, as soon as I'm like, oh wow, the tone is like
so...
This was so good.
What a great scene!
Wow, that was like so cinematic and so cool.
The game just brings me back to reminding me what I'm
playing.
I think this is...
Yeah.
Diane?
Diane, we did what we could, but we still lost her.
We?
Are we...
I'm not included in this.
It wasn't all your fault, George.
I'll go see what Willie wants to show us.
I'll leave the rest here to you.
Yes, okay.
Yeah, who's we?
Oh, dang it!
No, I wanted to talk to the other two.
Sorry.
Okay,
good.
Yeah, okay, it's the same observation.
York, I can still feel her hand.
Emily, it's okay.
Just try and calm down.
I'm going after Willie.
You just take it easy here, okay?
Come on, York.
Read the room.
She wants you to hold her.
And kiss her.
I called an ambulance, but it wasn't for me.
Oh, God.
He's doing that weird stance again.
What is he doing?
Ew.
Thomas.
Keep an eye on George and Nick.
We might still need it.
Make sure no one touches Diane's body either.
Thomas.
Keep it together, please.
I don't care what you're into, but save it for home!
Yes, dog?
I made the sinner sandwich and tried it.
I would give it a solid 6 out of 10.
Feels like it would be something a kid would make with
what's lying around in the pantry.
They still eat as an adult.
Yeah?
I believe that.
Yes?
maybe you have to walk with the dog is it important or what
I really though like sandwiches what was the center sandwich
it was like PB&J and like or not PB&J but like jam and
there's like fries or something or what was it on I like
because I like sandwiches with potato chips cereal and
turkey that's right cereal jelly and turkey Yeah, yeah,
that's right.
But if you've never had, like, a ham and cheese with, with,
like, potato chips, it's pretty good.
I'm a fan of that.
Why do you stop?
Keep leading me.
Come on.
Oh.
Yes?
I have all those things in my hand.
kitchen then you should give it a try maybe yes yes where'd
he go wait I lost him oh in here it's like a reverse escort
mission what is this what the dog doing for real though Wow
dog chase oh here we've been here before?
Oh, it's just open.
I...
Sorry.
I was waiting for that one to come out.
Lucky.
Lucky Gator.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Oh, you.
Here?
Oh.
I had real power behind it.
I sneak.
He is like an old man, like a grandpa.
I let out the force.
Yeah.
Anything over here?
No.
There's so much blood everywhere.
Okay.
If you want cursed video game food, I'd suggest looking.
Check out the Hanuda noodles from Forbidden Siren.
Let's say I know those one, that one.
Wait, there was, oh, the blood starts here.
Oh, here too, okay.
Yeah, dog.
He's just sniffing around now.
I think it's our turn to observe.
All right, let's go in then.
Kanuda noodles.
No, old men do not sneeze like that.
Don't ask me how I know.
Wait.
But the blood started here.
The blood starts where I'm standing.
I can barely see it.
Right there.
Oh, what's this?
Uh.
Okay.
Oh.
Thank you.
I don't want to change.
Okay.
Yes?
There's something here?
What?
Zach fell down the well!
Wait, I'm legitimately confused.
Wait, does this push over?
Oh, it does!
I'm not confused anymore.
Seed.
The plant!
Willie, are you out there?
Jason, what are you doing in there?
York, is that you?
Thank God.
I can't get this door open.
Can you unlock it from your side?
Does this not make him the most suspicious man?
Oh, stand away from the...
You gave him no!
You always...
Oh!
Kaysen, you dog.
Thank you for the sneeze.
Just curious, when you sneeze, does it taste like mint or a
phantom?
Taste?
Where's Diane?
And what are you doing here?
I stand correct if we do sneeze.
I was going to ask you the same thing.
Well, let's just say I have my reasons, you know.
Private reasons.
I don't really have to tell you, do I?
Actually, you do.
Diane just died a moment ago.
What?
Who else is gonna kissy my cheek?
You're now a suspect.
Yeah, you're now a suspect for real.
You need to tell me exactly what you were doing here.
Well, I just...
I just came here to talk with Diane.
To have a conversation.
And I suppose that kiss mark on your cheek is from your
conversation.
Ooh.
This was just a spur-of-the-moment thing.
Which is exactly what killed Diane.
okay okay i came here to be with diane you happy now i like
the song this this song is good yeah we've been together
before a couple times it's one of the reasons why i like
coming to this town see this time is no different i bumped
into her in a bar in seattle i had some some holiday coming
up Well, so I just took it and I drove her back here.
Max Omby, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I have a wife, you know.
But we've been separated for a while.
We're going through a divorce right now.
And I don't want her lawyer finding out.
Well, what about the seeds, mister, that were coming out of
her body?
Anyway, how could I kill Diane if I was in a room locked
from the outside?
Two hours ago, me and Diane, we were taking it easy,
drinking upstairs.
We were, you know, enjoying ourselves.
Then Nick had to show up.
Well, then Diane had a sudden change of heart.
She locked me up in here.
I don't think the lock was necessary, huh?
I've just been here waiting for her to come back, of course.
But she did.
Nice piano.
I heard footsteps a couple of times, but they just passed
by.
Oh, the killer.
Well, then I couldn't wait anymore.
So I let Willie here out through the window.
Then you showed up instead of Diane.
What's that?
What's down there?
Is that the same area that I was in?
Zach, Diane has become the third victim of our killer.
Because if so, it's like a tunnel.
And Nada from questioning Nick.
Nothing.
Got no new leads from questioning Nick.
There would be another exit, right?
He's taken the death of Diane really badly.
In shock, the works.
He claims to have liked talking with her about art.
But he also had a problem with her views about men.
He says that they argued, but not at a level that would lead
to a murder.
They were about to head out to the bar again together.
But while he was waiting for Diane, someone knocked him out
cold.
Oh.
He has no idea who it was, either.
Of course, Kaysen looks like a prime suspect.
But that door was locked from the outside.
There was no other way in or out of that room.
Hmm.
Which means there is no evidence of his involvement at this
time.
Not even the seeds?
Something else.
The footsteps he heard outside the room were not heels, but
a man's boots.
Yeah.
And Nick was wearing boots.
Oh!
But now that Diane's dead, no one can back up Nick's
statement.
Dun dun.
Which is why we have Nick in custody.
and have to let Kason go free.
That seemed like the only option, at least for now.
Poor Nick's wife.
George looked terribly depressed.
I guess this case is really getting to.
George looked depressed because he keeps killing people!
He is responsible!
He's away from him.
I wonder what's left.
But of course, he'd still have muscle.
He's the Conan of the story.
He's the Conan Edogawa.
Wherever he goes, he brings death.
Oh, we have to die by zombie.
Let's try that next time.
Yay!
I get paid.
Yeah, baby.
I want to see the death animation or death scene of us
getting killed by random zombie.
Two manslaughter's in a week.
Kind of a bummer.
The population of this town is now down to 15.
Oh my gosh.
How are they going to make it?
Zach, let's get back to the hotel.
Yeah, Zach.
First Anna, then Becky.
Now Diane.
I'm not looking forward to writing this investigation
report.
They're going to fire you.
York.
Do you have a moment?
What is it, George?
You're doing a terrible job at catching this guy.
There's something I'd like to talk to you about.
Do you have any time later?
yeah can't we just do it here yeah true possible i'd like to
go to a bar of course we don't really have to have you
caught feelings now that sounds like a good idea zach what
do you think we can go drinking with george or turn him down
and head back to the hotel oh we're gonna go drinking let's
go for a drink i'm not in the mood it's not up to you zach
it's not up to you george that Scarring your cheek.
Where did you get it?
This is so romantic.
This?
Didn't I tell you?
Well, it's not from work.
I got it when I was a kid.
A childhood injury.
Tree climbing?
I used to get a few scrapes myself climbing the big tree in
our backyard.
I used to climb it a lot.
And fall out of it a lot.
We can tell.
This wasn't anything like that, though.
who's my mother she did it no i'm sorry george don't worry
it's ancient history the world is flooded with unreasonable
violence the strong overpower the weak adults over children
men over women and criminals over their victims oh such a
strong sense of justice
i have no memories of my father is that ham before i knew
him my mother would hit me asked why someone ordered the
smallest plate of am i ate too slow left my shoes scattered
around tv volume too loud reasons to hit me hit me bad the
worst was what she called the tree punishment she'd whip my
back with these thin tree branches like a whip
to top us
I'm sorry.
Tree punishment was definitely...
Tree punishment?
Just hearing those words used to make you shiver.
They want to pass out.
And that's why I did not show you those scars on my back.
Oh, no.
Every time after the tree punishment, she'd always say the
same thing.
Turn to the tree.
This is hurting the tree.
More than it is hurting you.
Oh, my God!
To me.
Being a naive, dumb kid, Oh gosh, he read the giving tree.
I went to the woods to apologize to the trees.
Oh my god!
The Lorax appreciated that.
The Lorax remembered that.
The tree punishment is such a funny name for it though.
I kept asking myself, why is she hurting me this way?
Aww.
I've thought long and hard about it.
In the end, I've just figured I'm weaker than her.
That's why.
It's the law of Mother Nature at work.
Strong eat the weak.
But now, you have the power to protect the weak.
That's right.
Perhaps I should thank my mother for guiding me into this
line at work.
Yeah.
York listening so intently.
York.
I've been an arrogant fool, haven't I?
I haven't.
And if it weren't for me, both Becky and Diane would still
be alive.
Oh, George!
I could have saved them.
You could have.
Just listen to me.
You know, it's almost like they died because of me.
You're out of your mind.
Well, the first, definitely Becky.
I invited you to this bar for a drink.
But I guess this bar is my confession chamber.
And I wanted you to listen.
I'm waiting for life.
And to tell you.
Life is beautiful to start playing.
I'm waiting for you.
You must already hate me.
me for causing all these problems not following your orders
but I love you I'm sorry I'll follow your orders from now on
their hands will have my total cooperation their hands are
really close George you've been as cooperative as you can be
okay you even invited an FBI guy to a bar for George you're
just being nice now you've done a good job protecting this
town you just be and the folks here respect be honest with
them nobody can blame you for anything thanks I do feel a
little better.
We can be honest with him too, right?
Oh, George, you alright?
Talk.
Since we're here, why don't you talk to a few other people?
Okay.
I'll just finish off my drink.
Let me know before you leave, okay?
Okay.
Just...
Don't cry.
Carol.
Carol...
There's so many characters here.
Carol, I cannot remember.
She's like somebody's sister, I think?
Oh, I can finally get the money.
Is it my turn to be on the stage?
No, please!
Karaoke night!
Thomas's sister, that's right.
She's the only one we can talk to.
Unless we go...
Oh, I could save.
The game has only crashed on me once, but I fear I must save
every time.
I must save lots.
In fear of more crash.
Wasn't she the maniac driver?
She was!
Carol was the one trying to take me out!
That's so right!
Carol is very suspicious right now, if I remember correctly.
Ana life?
Like Anna, oh my gosh.
Wait, we can finally get this stuff now.
Yay!
They got idols out here?
Oh, yeah.
This place is awesome.
What's this?
Open?
Nothing?
Just going through the dressing room and nobody can stop me?
Hmm.
Okay, it's awfully quiet.
Oh, hello, Carol.
You.
Hey, Carol.
Becky is dead.
Diane, too.
We've got Nick in custody as a suspect.
Okay.
Wow, that's a lot of info.
Nick didn't do it.
I know.
I did it.
Carol, you took a locket from Diane, didn't you?
A locket with this mark.
got it what more oh oh that maybe show her maybe show her
the bark she can't see it if it's facing the other way oh
we get her singing again oh yeah
Is this what I looked like at the jazz club?
From Carol with Love.
Yes!
Wait, that's embarrassing.
I think I should have had a mic like that.
I'm kind of a fan of the Boa as well.
My man on the piano back there has gotten no sleep ever in
his life.
You had way more polygons than I had.
There's always next time.
Yeah, I'm taking notes.
If I ever get to sing at a jazz club again, I'll sing this
song.
And we can all pretend we're York.
Oh my god.
Ah!
Everyone can be like, hey, Zach.
Look at that.
I think he's on stage.
I can't understand these lyrics at all, though.
She's mumbling everything.
If I do another jazz show, I want everybody to cosplay York.
Like do Spider-Man meme.
With each other.
Oh my god.
Get my guys some.
That's makeup, right?
It has to be.
A room for...
full of yorks.
It would be so chaotic and stupid.
It would be the absolute best, actually.
Is
she in the...
Oh, Carol, we need to talk.
Why did you try to run me off the road?
My brother is at the sheriff's department, isn't it?
Poor guy having to watch over Nick who didn't even do
anything.
I'll start collecting flies.
no don't be stinky york but some of you guys can be clean
shaven york some of you guys can be beard to the floor york
some of you guys can be um and then the ladies you can also
be york or you could be emily or you could be george or you
could be thomas pick your pick anybody anybody's up for
grabs actually the men too anybody you could be york you
could be emily you could be george of Deadly Premonition.
Yeah.
Only the ladies can be George.
It's like how the girls, the girls that go see Pitbull and
they wear suits and bald caps and beards.
They all dress up as Pitbull and he loves it.
I love that too.
All right.
Come on, George.
Let's get you home, Grandpa.
Apparently, the song is called Miss Stiletto Shields.
Sorry to keep you waiting, boys.
Sack.
She turned into a goddess of the forest?
Let's forget work for a bit and drink a little, shall we?
What is this?
Why was her mouth like that?
I just thought the more of the merrier, you know, to relax
and get...
We should have gussied up!
I should have gotten...
Oh my god.
He's pooped.
George, I just got here and you're walking out on me.
I was hoping the three of us could have a drink and let out
this date.
I didn't need a man to man to woman.
He doesn't want a third wheel our day.
Oh my gosh, Emily is so cute.
George, you gentleman, you.
I think George likes you But he's avoiding you all at the
same time Wait what?
How astute There's a reason Nothing worth going into It's a
thing of the past Wait they were a thing?
They were?
I can't see it at all Wait what?
Okay He did ask me out When I first came to town i was still
in high school but i never really considered him my type and
there's the age gap thing too i respect him of course i
wouldn't take this job otherwise
of course of course not i came with my parents tell me about
them then sure why not he looks actually like her dad.
My dad dealt in stocks in New York.
He was hardly at home when I was a kid, always working.
Those pieces of paper were far more important to him than I
was, which is no different now, really.
I don't see much of him.
My mother, a totally different story, a wonderful person
that I still respect.
She was always kind and understanding.
Not only that, but she would always help me find my way.
be fierce too.
George is getting canceled up by stream.
We had our battles.
Three strikes.
You're out, George.
Too many.
You killed two women.
Cancer just before I graduated high school.
She gave this to me just before she died.
Oh god.
I take it with me wherever I go.
It's what I treasure most.
I thought it was a beetle.
I'm sure she's very out of you.
George, they're roasting you in the quote retweets.
George!
I defended you.
Yeah, I thought it was a cockroach, but it was like a little
necklace.
So funny.
Oh, Galaxy I had a good time tonight.
Good night.
See you tomorrow.
Wait, what happens to the audio?
Yes?
Yes.
Please, don't lie to us, okay?
Oh my god.
I won't.
Don't worry.
I think that's the loudest York has been this entire game.
No one cosplayed George anymore.
Have you got it?
cosplay George somebody will you'll get banned from me but I
can't believe we split a ham dish with that guy George
turned on the TV that doesn't matter watch it oh goodness
gracious it no one's gonna drive me home I've been drinking
all right what time is it oh it's almost it's almost 11 p.m.
Oh, shoot.
I forgot to get my driving.
Hold on.
I love the driving music.
I need my screenshot.
Okay.
Do I have my headlights on?
Oh, sorry.
I'm trying to turn.
There we go.
Oh, top.
Zach, picking up from where we left off.
Yes.
There's another really bad one around this time of year.
Three years ago, remember Zach?
No.
Yes, that's right, that one.
Yeah.
Multiple homicide, same ammo, across Utah, Colorado, and
Missouri.
I'm passing, oh shoot, where am I going?
Ah!
We're fine.
But after being run over so many times by a car, they didn't
look human.
Five victims in two months.
Oh, I think I remember this one.
The way he killed him is always the same.
But aside from that, there was nothing that linked the
victims together.
Well, they were all married.
But age, race, nothing else matched up.
Tire marks and fragments of paint ID'd the car that was
used.
How do I honk?
That's where things got really Oh, that's right.
The perpetrator...
Wait, we'll wait until he finishes this conversation.
Catalag Alante has a weapon.
Oh, the Cadillac Alante!
Armed strong no i don't feel like talking about this anymore
that senator's basement wait i feel like we heard this one
for sure forget what i saw there i mean we definitely heard
that one i thought we maybe i died you can change the car
camera view you can oh wait change view wait oh like this
wait oh change view oh my god wait This is huge.
I didn't know we could it go.
I Didn't know we could look like this.
Oh, but I feel so much more immersed like this
Game-changing No, I feel so immersed driving for real
Five episodes in Hey some babies learn the alphabet at age
one and some babies learn at age five
Zach let's go over our progress yes from what Olivia told us
and the sketchbook we found at Becky's house how many more
people will die before we find the killer there were a
couple of reasons for this first Becky gave the missing I'm
the baby I'm the baby yes also Nick has no alibi for when
Anna and Becky were killed.
We followed Nick to the art gallery, which led us,
unfortunately, to our third victim.
Yes.
The third victim, Diane.
Yeah.
Was strung up in the entrance hall of the art gallery.
It was art.
Her hands were tied, and a knife was sticking out of her
chest.
It was?
I didn't see that part.
However, there was a marked difference from the previous
crimes.
Do you remember what that was, Zach?
Wait, a difference?
multiple bodies no murder weapon it was right after the
crime what was right after the crime nope wait what that's
right that's right oh this suggests okay okay since the
crime was committed which means the criminal was still close
by and accurate yes there are two possible candidates nick
was knocked out in the entrance and one other zach who was
the other person in the gallery kason kason that's right
kason we followed willie good dog all the way to him we
followed willie good dog came out as follows i did not
murder that girl relationship.
That was why he visited the gallery.
Yes.
The two were in the middle of such a meeting when Nick
showed up.
Good dog, good dog.
Diane lost her cool and shut Kaysen up in the basement.
Now what did Kaysen hear when he was locked up?
Boots.
These boots.
Dog barking.
These boots are made for walking.
That's it.
The sound of boots passing by.
Boots and cats.
Nick was wearing boots that day.
It means it was likely that Diane met with Nick in her room.
Nick said he argued verbally with Diane about her playing
around with men, but they eventually decided to go out
drinking to make up.
However, immediately after that...
Who will talk about Picasso?
Nick was attacked by someone in the entrance hall and
knocked unconscious.
Supposedly.
We saw the rest.
Zach, do you think that Nick is our serial killer?
No.
Oh.
What?
Can someone draw me with the same reaction?
That's
so awesome!
I don't think so.
Me too.
Usha sent in a report too.
Usha!
The doctor!
We found a large volume of red seeds in Diane's stomach.
Yeah, we could tell.
She was coughing them up.
This confirms her as a victim of the raincoat killer.
Remaining leads.
locket which is in carol's possession the man with the
tattooed back and the upside-down peace sign yes there's a
lot left to answer I hope the coffee will give us more
guidance the coffee wait yeah how much more of the game
there's a lot left to answer Zach what did you think about
George pouring his heart out oh I was surprised It's the end
of a monarchy.
Just sitting in bed smiling about it.
Instead of Agent Morgan.
Oh, he did.
I didn't even notice that.
Oh.
What was that?
What the?
Emily?
What's going on?
Do you know what time it is?
I'm sorry.
I couldn't sleep, so...
No way.
I was drinking alone.
Oh!
She looks so ashamed.
My mother was a very kind woman.
She always smiled so brightly.
With cakes and cookies every day.
You heard what I can do!
She said I needed a sugar because I spent so much time
thinking.
My father was always quiet.
He never talked much.
He was a federal agent, just like me.
And he was hardly ever at home.
waiting for you on the couch.
I had a vivid imagination and I remember he once said this
to me.
There are plenty of crazy things in this world.
You don't have to go dreaming them up.
I can't believe you.
It's my job to make sense out of them.
One day you'll understand what I'm saying.
I found out later that my father was one of the first to
ever use criminal profiling to catch bad guys.
And so now I'm doing exactly the same job.
the fumble like father like son i think he doesn't care can
i ask you something are you autistic mind if it's something
personal i think she's gonna ask fire away
who's zach oh please oh um silly silly zach is a friend of
mine oh so you do have of friends on the record scratch he's
my only friend what kind of person is he then
i've never seen his face but he's always with me and we
discuss everything when did you become friends she has no
issue with that ago you're my arrow ace icon oh they're
on the oh three bottles i woke up one morning to hear my
mother crying in the living room advanced baddie phone was
normal so i had it in to see her trauma always gets me in
the mood too my mother i was so scared oh my god i close my
eyes so i i don't remember much more but I do remember the
words my father said to me at times we must purge things
from this world because they should not exist even if it
means losing someone that you love when I came back to my
senses they were both dead oh my god he shot my mother and
then killed himself murder suicide I'm so sorry don't worry
about it.
Zach's with me.
It was around that time that we became friends.
I'm here.
I'm with you, he said.
I'll be here always.
We can get through this together.
Life is Beautiful was playing just about one minute ago, by
the way.
That voice seemed to make me calmer.
Oh.
And here we are.
working together getting through things oh sorry this is the
first time I've ever told anyone about this Wow we was
really like I wonder if Zack will get angry that's a sad
story but I don't want you to take this the wrong way but
I'm sure there was a reason for what your father did wait
what well well thank you so much i'm having a blast i think
maybe i became an agent to find out why he did what he did
that's really messed up emily why would you say that oh oh
yeah why would you say that thank you whoa what for what is
emily the killer you saved my life oh my god the gallery i
would have died along with diane that.
I'm pretty useless.
I couldn't save Becky.
I couldn't save Diane.
What did you just say?
Useless?
I was never expecting to hear you say that.
They do the funny music.
Finally, you noticed?
It's a little slow, aren't you?
Maybe hopeless, but not useless.
Zach Do you think Emily got home safely?
She left Anyway, I think it's more serious of a situation
than I thought What?
Do you remember?
Our conversation with Emily She called me wrong but She's
really interested in you I think she's starting to have
certain feelings for you Is this guy's real?
If that's the case, Zach You and I are rivals This is a very
serious situation and Indeed.
Rivals!
What does that mean, York?
Well, if it comes to that, let it be a fair fight.
Agreed?
Don't look at me like that.
She likes the beard.
Oh my god.
Zach is gonna be pissed that he fumbled so badly.
Thomas!
Let me out of here!
Come on!
Thomas, Thomas, Thomas, Thomas!
Thomas, Thomas!
There's no toilet, toilet, toilet, toilet!
Thomas!
One second!
I know you're there!
I can't believe Emily is interested though, especially after
that story.
She was just like, okay, he's listening to a voice in his
head.
It's his friend.
Thomas!
Oh my god.
The game cut him off!
The peace mark.
The club...
Why didn't I find that outfit at the club?
Um...
Oh, the freaky lady on the ceiling!
Save, please.
The freaky lady on the ceiling.
Different club.
Oh, Zach Ville?
Yeah, so much happened in two hours for Ville.
You want to find out everything there is to know about
Diane?
York is leading the bar.
Wait, she's still alive.
Stop right there, Nick.
You're under arrest for the attempted murder of Diane.
Thomas, Thomas, Thomas, Thomas, Thomas.
Thomas, Thomas, Thomas.
Thomas.
It's time, it's time, it's time, it's...
I'm pretty useless.
I couldn't save Becky.
I couldn't save Diane.
Emily was thinking about getting impaled by the spikes.
We're back here!
Oh.
It's so different.
Episode 3!
Tea break.
It's not locked.
Are they all not locked?
Oh, yeah.
What about over here?
Oh, no.
Let's pick a door.
Number one!
It just locked?
Uh...
Number one?
This is Kingdom Hearts.
It locked?
So now are two locked or...
It wasn't locked?
Wasn't locked?
What...
Well this can't be!
The effects of the pedals are so cool.
I like it.
Pedals of Y.
Oh!
We did here!
Angel, Isaiah...
Wait, is this like the card?
Oh yeah!
Isaiah, Isaiah, Isaiah.
You can't say Isaiah.
Yeah, we found a card!
Okay, cool.
Um...
I feel like I'm pretty stupid with these quiet.
Isaiah.
Thank you.
This sounds like Kingdom Hearts music even.
When it's in here.
I'm going to be locked in here.
My mind palace for...
I feel like I was on the right track.
Finding the...
Oh!
Oh my god.
Okay.
I did it, thank you.
Who the hell is this person?
I had the same question.
Open this door.
There is no turning back.
You still want to enter?
Yes, I'm going alone.
No, it's nothing.
But I'm not alone.
I have Zach, right?
Right.
Yeah, I thought it's the guy in the wheelchair, Noel,
because of the things on his neck.
He just isn't wearing the mask and he's actually speaking to
us.
But I'm not going along, right?
I do.
It's better than staying here.
Someone like the Matrix architect said.
Very well.
Off you go, Mr. Hawk.
the kid from before so it was us is she gonna turn into a
zombie look carefully boy at times we must purge things from
this world because they should not exist even if it means
losing someone that you love
oh oh
The model for York's dad is actually the original prototype
design for York himself.
Oh, that's cool!
Do do do do do do do do do do do.
This game has so much potential to be like...
like so suspenseful and you know intrigued i mean it is
intriguing don't get me wrong it's just every it's every
tonal beat that it doesn't need to hit it's what's wrong
with his jacket why is it doing that mr morgan do you want
to refill yes please thank you so awesome is the coffee that
good mr morgan coffee is a vital investigative tool I know
exactly what to do oh my god let her have it Harry hurry
hour sale ad soon renovation start Monday red tags are two
for one yellow tags are 60% okay it says to hurry and the
first letter of each line is H Harry that's what I said
Harry yeah I saw it too Hurry to Harry.
Hurry to Harry.
Looks like the time that he was talking about has come.
Oh my god.
This girl paid the problematic rich boy who owns half a
day's home visit.
I...
Wait, I think I'm becoming...
Polly, I think I'm going to go see Harry today.
Oh, really?
He's a little strange, but I think he's the most trustworthy
one around here.
I think you'll have fun with him.
If you say so, Polly.
I'm getting Yorkified.
I'm seeing the vision.
Hurry to Harry.
Now, give me your cup, and I'll give you some more coffee.
It's just a comedy scene.
I don't need coffee.
I'll see you later, Polly.
Sure, we've seen another game where the sound is like...
Mr. Morgan!
What about the coffee?
Simultaneously makes and breaks the game list.
Your coffee!
Oh, can of tomato sauce.
We just eat that?
Kaysen.
What are you doing here?
Hey, am I still a suspect?
No.
Wait, no?
Okay, well, good.
My wife and I have been living separately for over three
years.
Okay, I don't care.
Just catch that.
Minto's brain is now in perfect sync with yours.
That's true.
I feel so bad for Diane though.
Gosh, did you find out who did it?
I can't discuss that.
I'm working on it!
Yes, of course.
I understand.
You don't have to tell any of the folks around town about me
and Diane, do you?
That's what you're worried about?
I won't do that.
I think I might.
But it's a small town.
I'm sure the rumors have started already.
Nothing to be ashamed of, right?
What's there to worry about?
I mean, what do you mean?
Nothing in particular.
No, nothing at all.
I'm clean.
As clean as the sheets in this hotel.
What's with that look?
We don't have a problem, right?
I don't, I don't, I don't like this guy.
It looks like Kasen is involved with another woman in town.
We can only hope it isn't Emily.
Wait, how did, oh, didn't he just leave?
What?
Oh
See you around, Kason Wait, how did you deduce that he's
with another woman?
Did I miss something that he said?
I can't get past the dog Oh my god Yes, I got past the dog
You I could take a walk right I could take a walk right I'm
not leaving town, don't worry.
I'm observing.
He's the huffing and puffing type of guy, but looks friendly
enough.
Dang, there's some sexy art in this hotel.
Bye, Polly!
Oh, shit, I'm talking.
What can I do for you, Mr. Morgan?
Oh, Mr. Morgan, what can I do for you?
Nothing, I guess.
Bye, Paulie!
Oh, fishing rod!
Wait, did she have one?
This game has so much heart.
It really does.
It really, really does.
It might be that he's worried about Ward getting around town
that he's with Diane if he's with another woman.
Who wasn't his wife.
Oh, that's fair.
Fishing rod and a worm from Paulie.
No!
Okay, we just won't go with Emily.
Maybe.
York, I can't find Thomas.
Was he here?
No, I haven't seen him.
Have you tried the radio?
I've been trying, but he's not answering.
What about Nick?
No problem with him.
He's calmed down a little.
Oh, thank goodness.
He's still saying you didn't do it.
Nick said that Thomas just appeared sometime during the
night.
Sorry, the music is too low, so I have to do something else
to make it so nobody can hear him.
I'm a bit worried.
George has asked for permission to search for Thomas.
I understand that things have been hard for Thomas, but
surely he's just resting at home.
But I'm not against looking for him.
Tell George that he has my blessing.
Okay.
As far as I know, Thomas always calls in when he needs a day
off.
We're human, and so we are limited.
We are human, and so we are limited.
As far as you know, there haven't been any serial killings
here before, right?
That's right, but that's not...
Emily, I'm going to see Harry today.
What?
Why?
We have plenty of other leads to follow, don't we?
He did invite me over, though.
It would be bad manners not to accept.
What's this look on his face?
His tongue just needs to be sticking out.
I feel the FBI would take a more logical approach to
investigations.
But Emily, the serial killer does not stay within the
boundaries of logic.
Thus, you can't hope to capture such a killer using only
logic.
That's why I'm going to see Harry.
I'm gonna go see Harry.
Blah.
Okay, sounds like a plan.
Great.
Thanks.
I was an idiot for thinking you might be a good pick.
I really need to work on my taste in men.
Is she having a stroke?
What's wrong with her face?
Emily?
What's wrong with your face?
Why was it like...
Hold on, let's go get that money and then we'll buy the...
Okay, good.
Emily didn't want to come with us.
She's disgusted in us now.
Batty fumbling complete.
I feel like I'm having a stroke too.
Dumb do do do do do.
Dumb doom doom doom.
Dang, breakfast is from 9 to 1.
That's crazy.
York is a maniac who eats whole cans of pickles and tomato
sauce, then fumbles women in chains, folks.
Can you...
This guy actually must smell all the time.
Oh.
He must smell really bad.
Rainy stripe.
Let's buy it.
Oh!
Nice.
Okay.
I love that Polly has...
bullets.
Flare.
Cigarette heavy.
Chocolate chip cookies for $15.
Crackers for 20.
Crackers are more expensive than chocolate chip cookies.
What is this?
Oh, the sugar donut.
Oh, bait, bait, bait, bait, bait, bait, bait, bait, bait,
bait, bait, bait, bait, bait.
The
bit.
Oh, Mr. Morgan, you do tote around a lot of stuff with you
already.
No!
Please!
Yes, we got the rod at least.
I got the rod.
Legend worm.
I think maybe we have some of the legend worm.
Bam.
Maybe.
Okay.
I think we've gotten bait before.
All right.
But we got a rod, so we're good.
Yeah!
Let's go!
Bullets probably cheaper than cookies.
Fireball!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Hot.
Hot dog.
Green tomato.
There.
How's that sound?
How do I get to the back?
Maybe the other way.
Because I see a fish back there.
I want to try.
I know we can do it.
Harry can wait.
Harry can wait a little bit.
I can't tell if we can get back here.
Back from here.
Maybe?
Maybe like this.
No!
Do I have to go all the way out?
Oh, oh, oh, my, oh my gosh.
Where's them?
Can we run in again?
It's so quiet.
No!
I can't get this way either!
It must be a backdoor in the hotel.
Dang.
That's fine.
That's fine, I guess.
Aw, man.
No, we're churropped.
Okay.
Toom.
Harry.
Yeah.
Zach, we've ended up with a third victim.
That dive I made at the gallery ended up being a wasted
attempt to save a life.
No, nothing's waste.
Oh, excuse me.
Passing on the ride?
Dive.
When's the last time I made a dive like that?
How long?
Oh, I remember.
Do you?
When?
It was in my late teens.
We used to go to those concerts.
You and I like punk rock, but we like different types of
punk.
You liked hard and heavy punk.
Like Crash and Sham 69.
I like the more twisted ones.
You would.
Buzzcocks?
You were a Buzzcocks fan?
The bands we really liked.
But for some reason, neither of us listened to the sex
pistols.
I wonder why that was.
It seems strange thinking about it now.
Don't judge me, though.
You're telling me not to judge this guy.
I think I have every ride.
Oh, oh.
My driving is not peak performance today.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, good.
Oh.
Excuse me.
We're in a tunnel.
Down, down, down.
There.
Okay, good, good, good.
Shortcut!
Nice.
Oh, gosh.
The road goes this way.
Is this a road?
What is this?
Yes.
Awesome.
Shortcut!
Passes you illegally.
I'm literally a cop.
I'm the FBI.
I can't do illegal things.
They'll, I'll be, I'll be, I'll be okay.
Don't worry about me.
What's this place?
Oh, this is Swery.
It's my birthday!
But it's been too cold for me to bother getting a cake, so
do you have an easy B-Day meal recommendation?
Also using B-Day Wish to wish you a good week, girl of mine!
Happy birthday!
A good birthday meal.
That's not too cold.
What if you get a hot brownie?
A hot brownie is always delicious.
With some ice.
Well, you don't have to have the ice cream, but.
A hot brownie.
That's a wonderful idea.
That's my suggestion.
Mmm.
It could have ice cream on it though if you want.
To melt?
Oh yeah.
You know what I've been obsessed with lately?
Tiramisu.
And we kind of...
When I was hanging out with Densetsu, we went to this
amazing, delicious tiramisu place.
Oh, oops, my bad.
Or rather, amazing, delicious Italian place.
and I was like oh my gosh I'm gonna get the tiramisu here
and I tried it and I was like I think I said something
blasphemous I was like guys I'm gonna can I say something
controversial and they were like yeah um Phoebe and Vicky
were like yeah what's up I was like I like the I was like I
like the tiramisu of Caesarea better than this fancy Italian
place Back in during Hallmat, I went to a restaurant.
Oh, I just saw that car spawn in.
I, um, I went to...
Hey!
Very bad catcher!
I went to a restaurant that had, like, this amazing trace
leches.
And ever since then, I've been trying to find something
similar.
Like, like, I've been eating tiramisu.
I've been trying to find, like, a delicious trace leches
that's, like, that just satisfies me as the...
As that restaurant and also the size area.
um oops this size area of tiramisu eating tiramisu
vicariously for me though i make a mean tiramisu i'll give
you an offering next time i make one please scuba gator
please i like it when it's really like watery or like really
wet you know what i mean I like it when it's real wet.
It was so, so good.
The translators that I had was like a pistachio.
I keep thinking about it.
Oh, chat is frozen.
Thank you.
Moist.
I like a moist, baby.
I'm done thinking about it, or else I'm going to get hungry.
I'm going to get hungry if I keep thinking about it.
Oh no, it's this song.
A song we can't hear anybody talking over.
Mr. Harry, open up!
Mr. Francis York Morgan.
A surveillance camera.
Finally, you have arrived.
You are welcome to come inside.
Oh, oh, thank goodness.
We made it.
Don't tell me I have to pay for this.
If I have to pay for this, I might scream.
he's a scammer he's a scammer oh my god are we for real
right now
whoa mr francis york morgan mr stewart has been waiting for
you to the meeting room you shall go to what was that a
rhyme mr stewart has been waiting for you to the meeting
room you shall go to.
What
just happened?
The meeting room is through here.
Please be kind.
Be sincere.
Thanks, Michael.
He's practically devoid of expression.
You'd almost think he was a robot.
Is it his ideals as a servant, or is there another reason?
Yes.
Mr. Francis York Morgan.
timing is now to meet Mr. Stewart.
You shall be kind and alert.
The timing is now and not tomorrow.
If you miss it, you'll feel sorrow.
Your meter.
So until your meeting is finished, I shall be locking the
front door.
Here's my next Valentine's card written.
If you get or become famished.
What we have, please use his yours.
Oh, he rhymed door with yours.
Michael really pushes some of these rhymes.
My poor guy probably has a notebook in his pocket, like
trying to be like, god damn it, I couldn't find something
that rhymed with Finnish.
Ugh.
Whoa.
I'm observing.
Symphony number three.
Eroica.
Symphony number five.
Fate.
Symphony number six.
Pastorelli.
Mmm, yummy.
Of the multitudes of musical scores, these three are the
only ones left open.
If Harry did this, it must have a meaning.
I could save again.
Wait, there's so much to do.
Okay, hold on.
Sure, take my money.
Does he have to pay his own phone to...
Every it's guest room number five.
It's unlocked.
Hotels aren't bad, but they've got good competition here.
Oh, we're going in.
We could sleep in here.
And we could shave?
Shave with no mirror?
You're a brave one, York.
Wait, what's this?
Umbrella for guest room number five.
Sure.
Is it for the symphonies?
Door wasn't locked.
I'll go in.
I bet the phone is like a church.
child's gunball machine he pays and then takes out the
change he does the thing where he puts the quarter on his
finger you know what i mean what is going on in this place
oh oh oh wait what just happened zach something is still
missing oh okay we need more clues i got you i know it a
statue cavalry apparently looks like it was meant to hold
something a springfield rifle do they hold the umbrellas.
Yeah, they hold the umbrellas.
I'm wondering if it unlocks this door or something.
Hold on.
Looks like the door wasn't locked.
What?
Okay.
I'm gonna get lost in here, I'm afraid.
Okay, we just went around.
Guess number three.
Let's grab the umbrellas that we can i think we need only
three and then we can go
oh here's and then we can go try the music thing too
resident evil mansion
oh that's the one we came through right yes
does he ever have real guests
okay yeah why does he have puzzles oh what's this high
quality beef better than the ham we got at the last place
all right i'll take that thank you very much I like the
color of this one.
I wish there was a wardrobe we could change our clothes.
I want to wear the new suit.
High quality beef.
What's this?
Guest room number one.
It doesn't seem locked.
We're guests, so why hesitate?
So true, York.
So true.
Oh, another one?
Oh, here!
We can change!
Yippee!
Oh, wow.
Yes.
It's looking a bit dirty.
Okay, we'll get this one cleaned.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
Wow.
Yeah, fresh.
Dang.
Oh, my goodness.
Goodness, we look like a candy cane.
Reed's drawing room.
The door's locked and there's no keyhole.
Could there be another way?
Okay, so yeah.
That's basically what we're doing the puzzle for.
Did I go in number four?
No, I did not.
Oh, and this is where we change our guns and stuff.
Someone left their guns in their room?
Alright, so we got, I think, all of the umbrellas.
Let's go back here.
Is this guy also supposed to be holding one?
Symphony number three.
Five, six.
Three, five, six.
Maybe I only needed to grab those boys.
Maybe I'm silly.
Oh, well.
I don't think there was anything in this hallway.
Nope.
Yeah, free umbrellas, whatever.
I misread there being a tea.
Yeah, it's kind of funky.
Okay, so three.
Okay, nice design.
Oh!
Okay.
five wait six we didn't find a room six did we okay kind of
freaky room
six what was this one three
oh it's so quiet
Oh, just kidding.
Wait.
Why so many guest rooms?
Did I go in here?
If you sprint while opening the door, you'll go fast.
Oh, I forgot about that.
Someone did...
Here it is.
Okay.
Someone did tell me about that before.
Thank you so much.
I forgot.
Thank you, Vapun.
It might have been you.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Do they change?
You think they change the numbers every day?
That'd be kind of crazy.
I don't know how stairs work.
Oh, dang it.
I forgot to do it.
I thought you weren't doing it on purpose.
Nah, I just forget sometimes.
Harry!
I know what your face looks like.
I dreamt about you last night.
I dreamt about you last night You were in my dreams
Mr. Francis York Moore Please have some tea while it is hot
Too much coffee for your body will make it rot Dang What
about all the cigarettes that he smokes Almost as though you
knew I would be coming today is particular about the best
timing for all things.
Now please, drink some tea and enjoy the good health it
brings.
I'm sorry, Harry, but I just don't like tea.
Bring him a cigarette.
Bring him tea that tastes like cigarettes.
Mr. Francis York Morgan, some tea with sugar is what's best
admired.
That looks so tired.
So says Mr. Stewart.
Sugar?
Are you gonna kiss me?
What's in the sugar?
Oh my god!
He wants me to...
Where did you get these seeds?
He wants me to drink the seeds!
Wait, is this a new song?
Oh, oh, oh.
Sure has a lot to say.
Mr. Francis Yorkmorth.
Seeds were found in our town in a certain specific place
More seeds are there you will see when you find that certain
space Did he just rhyme certain space with certain space
Wait, no wait did he rhyme certain place with certain space
and then again with certain place Certain place certain
space so you must Let's go back to that certain place.
Mr. Francis, you're mortal.
Can you speak up?
I can't for you to find this location.
It is most crowded and most quiet.
And gives a cold sensation.
Nice crowded and most quiet.
So says.
Mr. Stewart.
I can't hear your hint over the music.
So you're not going to talk unless I- And crowded?
Yeah, a cemetery, right?
That's what I was thinking.
Oh,
we've been to the cemetery.
We slept there before.
I remember there was, like, that one hole that was dug.
Oh, my gosh.
Do you think it's the weird grave digger guy?
There.
Zach, let the treasure hunt begin.
Full of green tomatoes.
And yet it is very quiet there.
Have you figured it out, Zach?
Oh, yeah.
Must be the graveyard.
Oh, that's what I said!
Yeah, that's what I said.
None of them can speak.
You see?
So let's get going to the graveyard.
The game holds your hand a little bit.
Yeah!
To the graveyard!
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba!
So says Miss Minto.
No time to waste.
We must...
Hello?
Why can't I move?
Zach, we're supposed to play along with Harry's little game.
Yeah, someone got us stuck.
I don't like being played with either.
But we've got three victims now.
And we need to prevent that number from becoming a four.
Wait, where are we going?
This away.
Shortcut!
Don't worry about the car damage!
Don't worry about it!
Are those cows?
I'll have to truck.
Shortcut!
The damage of the car is not going down.
Don't worry.
It's fine.
I'll pay for it with all my money.
This is a really fast car.
I'm going like so speed.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, sorry.
We're fine.
The car is in mint condition.
Because I'm driving it.
You don't need to worry, you're pretty little head.
Oh, shh.
Where are we?
What is that?
Oh!
Did we just end up on a train truck?
Wait.
Where are we?
How do I get home?
Wait.
Can we drive through here?
Oh!
Nope, we cannot.
Oh, talk!
Yeah, you're right.
I missed it, I missed it.
Talk.
You know what?
There was one band that we both liked.
What's that?
We went all the way to New York to see them play.
Right, Zach?
It took us hours to get to New York by bus.
We got to the CBGV.
We were so nervous we couldn't go inside.
What?
It took us 30 minutes to gather enough courage to go inside.
And inside, we were shot.
Right, Zach?
Why were you shocked?
You never forget that feeling.
It was like a Blitzkrieg.
Blitzkrieg pop.
Ah!
That song still makes me feel good.
I had a gamer infl- That's a sign of a classic.
Instincts.
Reflex.
We're fine.
Those were the good old days.
Rock and roll high school and Chinese rock.
Sheena is a punk rocker and surfing bird.
And I was so depressed when I heard the news of the deaths.
Original punk is one of the greatest.
We're a little lost, but we're fine.
I think we're on the right track now, everybody.
I think we're on the right road.
I'm in condition, so it's cute, endlessly charming.
Oh, look at that!
It's right there!
Floor it!
That was so much faster than the road.
They were talking about what?
A band?
I was too busy.
I was, I was focused on the road, you guys.
Just as Harry said, it's crowded and quiet.
What?
Eek!
Hey, Brian.
Brian?
Are you alive?
Mr. Agent, how are you?
Oh, not bad.
Uh-oh, the sky.
I'm, uh, just playing a little game with Harry.
Uh-oh, the sky, you guys.
A game?
Is that fun?
We've only just started, Brian.
The fun is about...
I don't know why we don't gather everyone in the town and
look at their backs, you know?
Actually, is there a tree in the graveyard that drops red
seeds?
Seeds.
Red seeds?
I slept in that bed.
That tree does.
And that one, too.
All red seeds.
All we had to do was turn around.
Oh, my God.
Oh, let's get our tomatoes.
Yeah, free tomato.
Who would have guessed?
Oh, look, free tomato.
Everyone's scamming me out of my money in this place.
It sounded a little spooky.
It sounded a little creepy.
Can I get in?
Open the door?
Wow, there's a bone here that I've been trying to get.
Wait, how do I actually get in though?
Legitimate question.
Wait, can I not?
Oh my god, there's a guy there.
Oh my gosh.
He's so low FPS.
What happened to you?
Nice shot.
Oops.
Oh, game over?
Yeah, we should.
We should.
You're so right.
Let's game over.
Okay, let's game over.
Right?
Pretty sure I did.
Yeah, it took my money.
I don't know why he's so low FPS.
Yeah, okay.
We're good, though.
Just for anybody who wants extra reassurance.
Alright, kill me!
Oh!
Okay, kill me?
How do you get behind me?
Oh.
Kill me?
Anyway.
There's plenty of guys here.
Kill me?
My eyes!
get her off of me get her off of me
oh my god my eyes for real though this is terrible
oh my god
wait there was a period what just happened there was like a
second guy trying to get on us wait what just happened
was that a That doesn't seem like it was supposed to be the
way it happens.
Wait, what?
It was a glitch?
So there's supposed to be a funny cutscene.
Oh, hold on.
Let's...
Wait, can I skip this?
Just as Harry said.
I can't.
It's crowded and quiet.
Okay.
No, I don't want to go through the cutscene again.
Okay, we got it, we got it, we got it, okay, good.
Okay.
Oh.
The game feels a little funky at the moment.
Is it just me?
Okay.
Or does the game feel funky?
Oh, gosh.
I think we gotta just kind of speed through here.
I'm running.
Which way am I going?
Oh, God.
Get up.
Get up, get up, get up.
Oh my god, the camera angle.
Oh,
I had to push.
Oh, I think that's him.
I thought there was somebody behind me.
I was scared.
Run!
Stop pushing!
Okay, we're safe.
Oh no, I want the bow!
My sword is almost broken, though.
We're gonna have to get another one.
Let's get back to Harry's.
What?
The reward better be good.
You got red seeds.
But you know about these seeds.
Wait, what's wrong with this shirt?
They were right here under my nose.
It's as if I was carefully carrying a bottle of water.
While walking in a pool.
I tried pressing start.
It only let me skip it at a certain point.
Like,
uh...
The game seems a bit glitchy at the moment.
I'm not sure why.
Oh, we're back to normal.
Oh, there's a dog in here.
Oh, wait, is he going to take my bone?
Don't take my bone, dog.
I'm going to have to buy another sword.
This thing is, like, OP, though.
It's awesome.
Left foot bone.
It's the craziest game of Twister ever.
A human bone?
This doesn't look related to the case, but shouldn't I let
someone know?
A bone in a graveyard?
It's not that bizarre, though.
I don't
remember these here.
Can I leave this way?
I have to go all the way back around.
Pet the dog.
You're the cop.
Yeah!
I'm the police!
Who am I letting know?
Did you guys like my little Metal Gear Rising arc that I had
right then going through this pathway?
Did you guys like that?
Oh my gosh, you mean I have to drive all the way back?
It's 11.
Oh, Brian, you're still alive.
Oh my gosh.
Yoink.
It was sick.
Yeah.
Brian's like, I'm still standing.
You, you, you.
I'm still standing.
We will have to.
Maybe like once I restart the game or something.
Either next stream.
We, uh.
We.
Um, get attacked again and die.
to regular zombie because apparently it's supposed to be
like a crazy cutscene i feel like i missed out on it oh i
think though i'll call it it's a little bit early but i
think i'll call it here no no let's get to harry's no i'm
just i'm a liar i want to know what harry is gonna say i
mean sorry mr stewart i'm a big liar what just a little bit
more just a little bit more
here because I don't want to take that one back just just a
little bit I'm the lying liar yeah okay this one's good all
right yeah no
damage run didn't deny the sword its purpose, right, Zack?
Just...
Uh...
So, Zack...
About Emily.
What about Emily?
My first impression, when we met her on that bridge, is...
slightly different from what I think about her now.
Yeah?
Don't you think she's pretty mesmerizing?
Oh, I think I'm going the wrong way.
She seemed interested in you.
Did you make a move on her?
No, don't answer.
I'm just asking.
but if you like her I won't stand in your way but I'd like
to hear the truth Zach you dog could affect our friendship
you know me I'm just interested in her that's all interest
oh I see oh my god you are so you are so dense as you know
Zach I'm cautious with women it's because I was badly burned
in my last relationship You were in a relationship?
Wait.
That's my problem.
You're pretty friendly with the ladies, aren't you?
Can I go this way?
Maybe you should teach me about how to interact with women.
Oh, no, it ends.
He says I'm good with women.
Don't act so surprised.
What?
Like, he was in a relationship before?
don't get me wrong york is a stand-up guy oh wait
there's the pathway okay cool I know how to get home I mean
to Harry it isn't love or anything don't get it twisted you
babaka come on Zach it's not like I love her it's not like
it was love at first sight or anything seeing her standing
on that bridge with the sun glistening in her hair, the
slight smile on her face, and the wind in her blonde hair.
I don't even know she's blonde.
Why are you making, why are you putting words in my mouth?
Come on, Zach.
This isn't who you are.
Zach, you've changed ever since you met her.
The actual halo.
Uh-oh.
I think my car's about to break down.
It's turning red.
Is that bad?
What's so fine?
We're only 800 yards away.
We can pay it off.
I can't let my car die.
I can't let it die.
Oh no.
I'm dying.
He demanded Zach always be allowed to join on the dates.
And after the third wheel got tired, so...
No!
Okay, we're all right.
Just pull into the parking lot.
Nice and easy.
Chat's frozen.
Oh, thank you!
A surveillance camera.
Mr. Francis York Morgan.
Finally, you have arrived.
Nico-nie!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Nice and easy at 60 miles per hour.
Look, it's not my fault that that's a really fast car.
Alright, let's save.
Do I have to do another puzzle?
You think they reset the numbers?
I have the rest of the umbrellas, right?
So...
He doesn't even greet me!
Mr. Francis York Morgan, please proceed to Mr. Stewart's
room.
There he awaits you, I shall assume.
oh yeah the game feels like it's starting to break a little
or something i'm scared i'm scared
no way is it really 14 23 and 26 a passionata Wait, what was
it, 14, 23, 26?
Door wasn't locked.
Oh, what?
Uh, hold on.
Let's go down here first.
It's locked.
Uh, it's locked.
Unlocked.
Where are we going?
Oh,
it's locked?
Oh, I forgot that I can run through the doors.
Oh my gosh.
I'll do it this time for sure.
Uh...
Oh, there's... Wait, no, that's not a door.
Oh my god, I thought that was a man.
Like a living man.
I'm in a room?
Okay.
Oh, there's something on the toilet.
A can of pineapples.
Obviously.
Why wouldn't there be a can of pineapples on the toilet?
duh anybody that's oh oh this one's locked wait I thought I
said it wasn't locked uh oh it's not like umbrellas like
before is it oh no I have to push things okay
14 23 26 uh uh
Wait.
So it'll be like 1.14, right?
Stop!
Where is it?
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Or no, I get it.
I get it.
I push it to, what, 10-4?
Rig.
Okay.
No, no.
Keep going.
14.
This is the Resident Evil experience.
No, keep going.
Keep going.
10-4?
All right, stop, stop.
now stop
okay 23
oh my god please keep pushing push push push push push
Push!
I wish I could like push faster.
I see the head!
That's two, right?
Yeah.
Okay, three.
It's a boy!
Oh my gosh, it's triplets!
Ah!
Six.
I can't imagine his back after this.
One more, one more.
Yay!
Flash, flash, flash!
Yeah.
I think it's disgusting that somebody has to do this every
day.
Somebody has to do this every day.
To this poor.
To go around.
The poor maids.
Can you imagine?
As a maid myself, I feel scared.
And I'm going to shoot.
a gun in this man's house?
There we go.
It's a living.
What is it?
Aren't the dinosaurs in, um, the Flintstones say that?
Eh, it's a living.
Whoa.
Oh.
Where?
Oh, there I am.
I was scared I wasn't going to show up.
No, the maids!
I can hear the maid being like, I have to solve that damn
puzzle to come in here and sweep that up.
Harry, turns out what you said was true.
And I'd like to hear more.
York, as you know, there's a powerful mystery surrounding
these seeds.
You've seen them at those other murders that took place
elsewhere.
And you've seen them deeply involved with the murders that
they still do well.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's right.
But how do you know all this?
I am also a seed.
It turns into...
Youngsters tend to hurry so much that they let things slip
right past them.
What you need to do is slow down.
this down a bit that way you'll see what's really important
he's gonna make your controller move yeah 50 years ago when
the war was over just about when the communist red started
to become a rising threat no he doesn't speak in ron a town
constructed a huge clock tower clock tower then
Oh!
I hope you're ready for the plot to get crazy.
I'm so ready.
The legend of the raincoat killer?
Yeah?
Stop playing games with me, Harry.
That's nothing more than folklore.
I thought we said it wasn't more than folklore.
The FBI has no such record of a multiple homicide case in
this town.
Croft Betty.
York, Anna, Becky,
their deaths are real.
Yeah.
Not folklore, not legend.
The raincoat kill
the public.
Whoa.
In fact, the one,
tell me, who do you think would be able to do some?
The military.
Very good.
The model's doing it.
But if there are no records about it, then how do you know
it really has?
The military's involved?
The Patriots?
Good question, York.
Why would I know this?
I am the military.
I was there.
Yeah.
I saw it with my own eyes.
Oh!
The brutal killer himself.
But we can do better than that.
No, I think we should talk about it right now.
When we need to talk,
a killer...
Yes?
New!
New Age Raincoat Killer.
Oh!
No raincoat, yes.
Let's call him...
that real one are you the real one what you want to know new
one is he the one that was the original between 10 and 20
years ago that's how he would know as a copycat i noticed
that these red seeds were special and then he would also
know about the seeds right yeah human imagination can lead
to tragedy sometimes someone lent the red seeds to the
serial killer legend it if you eat the red seeds and then
kill someone you will become immortal this new fabricated
legend that's why he tried to feed me the seeds
our this house placement is crazy but also the camera is
moving behind us wait oh no the camera I'm just panicking.
Sorry.
I was looking outside.
Okay, anyway.
Oh,
yeah, yeah.
People on the other side.
I was too busy looking at the rock outside.
And no seeds might be growing in different parts of the
world.
So you're saying that the series of cases I've been
following are all linked to this town.
That's interesting, Harry.
But there's no evidence to support that story.
None of the criminals we caught for the other murders ever
mentioned anything like that.
Oh.
It's your job.
And then you are role in duty to...
Speak up!
Must go on.
You know I said that the incident 50 years ago was totally
erased.
Yes?
Well, not quite.
Oh.
Records still exist in the show.
Sheriff's office.
The old sheriff back then hated the military.
He did his own investigation.
Oh, yeah.
I need you to bring those documents here to me.
Why, so you can destroy them so you can't be named as the
Rango killer?
I'll tell you everything I know.
Uh-huh.
Critical wacky lore.
Okay, it's worth a look.
And we may as well let the old man have his fun.
Bring me the only surviving documents of the evidence about
the original raincoat killer.
Yes, I would like to see them.
Please, please.
Yeah, I better copy those documents first.
For real.
Hmm.
That is the worst turkey sandwich I've ever seen.
Why is your turkey purple?
Country ham.
God damn.
Documents from a case that happened 50 years ago.
Let's play along with the old man for a little longer, shall
we?
Zach, that means we need to head for the sheriff's
department.
Okay, I have a question.
For anybody that knows this game.
Holy cow, 4,000 yards away.
this game realistically how much longer do i have i'm just
curious because i need to figure out like stream schedule
wise i feel like i'm a while still a bit okay okay that's
fine that's fine i wasn't gonna try and like go on to or
rather i was like if i had like an hour left then i could
obviously do it but three to four hours is not bad at all
okay okay that's super easy
two to three more streams okay okay two streams we could do
that we could do that yeah probably two more streams okay
that's not bad at all then well then next time we will go to
the sheriff's office and we will we will find the files york
i need you to break into this government building to steal
these incriminating documents so I could see though.
Exactly his thought.
Yeah!
It says 18 to 23 hours average.
So you're like halfway there.
Hmm.
I guess so maybe.
Well, I don't know.
I guess it depends.
I feel like this is a tough game to get an average on.
Maybe if you go from mission to mission to mission to
mission.
But You know, if you do side missions, that's obviously
going to add more.
But yeah.
Um, maybe a long stream and a standard one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um, I'm definitely, I'm having so much fun with the game.
I just, it's not like I'm like, oh my gosh, I want it over
with.
I was just asking so that I know what to plan for future,
for future, uh, stream schedules and all cool yay yay well
then thank you guys so much for more deadly premonition it's
hard to gauge this game's pace it really is but i think we
made crazy good progress this time so yeah even if it's two
streams three streams it's all good thank you for the stream
it was most peem perhaps next time you shall get your wish
and be able to catch one fish or two fish or perhaps redfish
or bluefish though we weep since you must fade from our
sight we hope you have a most wonderful night thank you
darko so says mr chat thank you thank you thank you this
game i i this game oh just does not ever fail to make me
laugh or also make me go
It's so...
Oh my gosh.
I feel like this game was made for me.
I'm so happy it exists.
It's the game that keeps on giving.
Truly, truly.
But we shall...
I think we only heard life is beautiful one time this
stream.
Life is beautiful will never stop being funny for me.
Right?
Um...
It's made for goofballs.
I love being a goofball!
Yeah, one but a good one.
After we trauma dumped to Emily.
Yeah, we didn't hear so much today.
Oh, it's so funny.
It's so funny.
Ah.
But yeah, we'll continue.
say win for sure because not so long but just because of my
stream moving schedule and streaming schedule i thought
about this i was like okay i move and then i was like will i
have internet
um i moved this week and now i'm like will i have internet
when i get there so that i did not think of um yeah it
usually takes a little time to set up um so uh might be a
couple days off well actually there will be some days off
next week uh but it will be a little couple days off once i
move and everything um i'm really sorry that i can't give
you a definite time when i'll be back um uh status status is
away welcome to membership thank you Thank you so much.
But I'll let you guys know once I have internet.
And then, of course, I'll be good to go.
I imagine probably at least, like, a week off as I get
internet and get settled a little bit and stuff.
But that's not until later this week.
So we'll wait for you as always, boss you.
See you soon.
Thank you.
I will probably do some, like, Twitter spaces in the
meantime.
time or something like that so yeah okie dokie okie dokie
thank you so much everybody thank you thank you thank you
for being understanding and thanks for keeping me company
and thanks for watching and thanks for laughing and thanks
for hanging out and thanks for being so awesome i love you
guys so much i will see you guys when i see you next and oh
i will not be streaming tomorrow i got a pack all day um but
Thank you, picnic, thank you!
So much for the picnic, thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you so much.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
Did I save?
Wait, wait, did I save the game?
I know I saved inside his mansion, but I don't want to do
that again.
I don't think you saved.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, there's a phone!
Where?
I see it on the map.
Where is it?
Oh, here it is.
Okay.
Never mind.
Okay, bye.
Oh my god.
Wait, I've been... Oh my gosh.
I went to go talk to you guys.
Oh my gosh.
My mic is on.
I will be rating it to Vicky.
She is trying also to get to 50,000.
She's so close.
So make sure you go.
And, um...
Is she in 3D?
what is this when does she have a 3d oh make sure you go and
um subscribe to vicky and yeah okay bye-bye it's been like
this for three streams oh my god oh my god oops bye